[Music]
I'm in San Diego at SeaWorld and until
the end of April they have this super
high quality penguin camera that they're
doing in conjunction with the Discovery
Channel and their Frozen Planet series
and they asked me if I wanted to come
down and hang out with penguins I said
yes SeaWorld she is my penguin
ambassador you're gonna be helping
familiarize me with the Penguins routine
and introducing me to them later right
you got it we're gonna suit you up we're
gonna prep some food for the Penguins
we're gonna go upstairs get a chance to
feed them and take care of some of their
habitat okay great now how often do you
have visitors here it's newer yeah yeah
you know but I know that I mean like
people like you know are special
probably would people like me a good to
come backstage all the time really
we've got Martha Stewart got Glenn Close
you know that actually looks like some
kind of sexual harassment really what we
wear to work with all the Penguins so we
gotta get you suited up let go I'm ready
yes you are I'm ready to chop up fish or
no Bertha cow
[Music]
oh look yes tis Delmar means party of
the sea and then that not look like a
Barbie we're just going in here are we
trying to resuscitate them what usually
takes at least 30 minutes 30 minutes to
follow this out I'm on TV I don't have a
[ __ ] come here Jason he works with me I
don't know what he does we'll be back in
half an hour you got it all right well I
have one more wardrobe change just
because I want to fit in so give me a
minute all right
all right so here we are here is the
penguin encounter what you've got right
in front of you here these are some of
the different types
these are macaroni penguins yeah they're
one of the friendliest species that we
have you know just come over to take a
look they're really curious
they're super social so they spend a lot
of time together as a colony over
dependence of the graves we're making
television thank you anyway
all right well what's an except who's
hungry and they are close to the bucket
Hampi is a really important part of our
day hanford oh there we go
yes swallow it down I'd stop shooting
something for the show and I'm really at
this point activist feeding penguins if
you look at the pool there's a lot of
birds that are just swimming around so I
want to make sure they have some fish
too
this is how I feed my kids in the
summertime so this is the snow hose yes
sir we're looking at and we're gonna get
us a little bit of extra snow for the
birds
okay although like this or you can hold
the house cameras over here kind of in
the crook bry your hip oh I am I
definitely I think you know it's way I'm
gonna all this be standing here waiting
all right there we go stem right yeah I
gotta go
turn movies now
[Music]
yeah I thought so
yeah that's right
in our house when there's poop on the
floor just cover it
[Applause]
to my little smell bread
it's really cold
[Music]
all right Kayla thank you very much
you wanna showing me around I really
appreciate it and thank you nice work
guys good job again follow today Andy
Richter reporting from SeaWorld check
these guys out on the web